i was watching pawn stars and somebody
brought in a computer
the pawn stars to pawn and it was the
like uh the version two or the original
one from the 80s and they're telling the
story and they said that you would go
around to in palo alto and fix people's
you'd do house calls and fix people's
actual computers
and i just thought that was
i mean i had in earlier days much
earlier days oh my gosh anybody called
me had a problem i would go down help
them out but that was when you could
actually fix them you actually knew
every bit of code in there you knew what
was wrong how to find it nowadays it's
just too much of a mess for
a human to do very much you know how
would you even find if your computer has
malware
millions of bytes of code you can't find
it
you know even an expert can't really
find and determine necessarily that
you've got something's hurting you so
that's how it is today is that just
because of that's how technology has
progressed or is that sort of by design
that it's not it's how it progressed
because we could always it moore's law
we were you know when we started apple
you go and put about 2 000 transistors
neurons on a chip and now you can put 60
billion on one chip for 25 cents
manufacturing costs maybe made with
inflation's up to 50 cents yeah but um
yeah it's gotten way too complicated i
long all the time janet would tell you
all the time for the the old school the
old school ways and the old days
uh you know when you actually own stuff
too
now you can just rent it especially look
at a car like a like a like a tesla
they'll just totally take your world
that you know and totally change it you
can't find things and you can't operate
them and if one little button you need
to be able to get to something with your
voice isn't working you can't get to
that feature at all until they take over
it's been two months or something trying
to get a button replaced one button on
the steering wheel
the worst service of our lives man we
would never buy another tesla wow but we
have an electric car in order but it's
it's a newer one 520 miles range tesla
canceled their caller car that was going
to be like that and um 20 and it charges
at 350 kilowatt speed tests our tesla
only charges at 140 max so it'll be much
quicker charging on the road you can
drive all the way to la in that car and
no charge at all and usually your hotel
has something to change what company is
that the uh
lucid lucid lucid new company they have
a showroom that we went to we passed by
on the street and janet saw it on the
side so we turned around and went in
there and in the showroom in beverly
hills and we were also by one that we
saw from the outside in um
scottsdale fashion mall
so
they're opening up their showrooms but
it's kind of it's costly to bring a new
car like that to the market it's yeah
it's still a bit of an expensive car and
they haven't made very many lucids yet
you said
uh if you want to do something with
voice command and that is just it makes
me so interested they turned off the the
user interface menu to do some things
and the only way you can do it with is
with voice but if the voice button is
broken i've had a break on me once
before and
intake didn't take two months to get
fixed we drive we've driven the tesla
for a long time lots of long road trips
we've taken at least eight three
thousand mile round trips to kansas and
back and many to
yellowstone and back and we've gone up
to canada we just love driving all the
time during during 2020 co-vid
restrictions stay at home we just got in
our car it's an extension of our home
and we drove to every corner california
and back the same day
you know way up 10 hours up to eureka
and 10 hours back wow the mendocino
forest oh redwood forest never ever
forget it and we went to all the
national parks in california and saw the
biggest trees in the world and all that
you know so that was that was really a
great little escape but um the tesla
when it's navigating it just makes if
you ever put on turn on its features
well anything actually just cruise
control
the number of times we've been on an
interstate we drive 10 40 70 and 80 all
the time and then we're on interstate
and all of a sudden we're going 75 miles
an hour and all of a sudden the car
screeches the brakes the dogs get thrown
forward and it slows down if there's
nobody in the rearview mirror that we
have to speed up for i let it go all the
way down go down 25 miles an hour on an
interstate a tesla with nothing around
no cars around no nothing sometimes
there is a car around you say that must
have been it but sometimes with nothing
around this is so dangerous it's
happened to us a hundred times at least
because we drive so much and then if you
turn on the steering where it's steering
my gosh sometimes it kind of goes over
the line a little and there's a truck
right there or if a truck kind of moves
towards you a little you should a human
driver would just pull away a few inches
and it doesn't do that and i remember
recently just recently once
i'm driving along
and all of a sudden there's a semi on my
right the car lurched towards the semi
and i had to quickly grab control wow i
mean that would have been
death this is just
horrible horrible assuming that these
algorithms can do what a dumbest human
could do okay you're on a freeway and
there's a big there's and there's
there's a merger lane coming in well
tesla starts driving it the lane gets
wider where it is on the lines and it
starts driving like a drunk person but
the car coming up ahead as a smart human
you would just see we're going to call
we're going to be equal so i'll back off
a little just easy to do tesla gets let
you go right up next to it and it
screeches the brake on to get out of the
way you know because it has to by then
this is just not the way human beings
ever think
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and
sky jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
yeah
[Applause]
you